valerie is writing in high oven and John
how and where can we attract high-end
interior designers for our luxury
furniture platform what kind of topics
would be interested in for high-end b2b
leads so trying to attract high in
interior designers for a luxury
furniture platform I would start and on
the research for this phase of things
and really doing the due diligence
online and figuring out the associations
and organizations that are attributed to
that to the high-end brand or vertical
that you want to really get involved
with and market too so it's starting
there and just figuring reaching out to
those those organizations if people are
using LinkedIn premium and be able to
send in males to decision-makers at the
different organizations that's something
I use here at a weber is it is a little
bit of an investment on your end but I
think at the end of the day it's well
worth does those discussions that you
might be able to establish and kind of
doing doing something like that speaking
of which some other I guess cool tools
if you want to call them that that i use
in terms of trying to break into
organizations like that the linkedin
premium is certainly one thing that i
found huge there's a app called similar
web that you might want to check out
it's a google chrome extension so it
gives you the lot about that that
website in that domain so when you come
to Evan Carmichael com using similar web
you're able to see where he ranks in
terms are where Evan ranks in terms of
the is Alexa ranking both domestic and
international another cool thing about
that it gives you a similar
organizations or similar websites that
you might want to be able to target to
so definitely check out that that's
something that again it's really just
finding that that one potential partner
and be able to branch out from there I
think you can use that and all across
the board in terms of your research and
going after other potential targets that
you want to go after yeah to add to that
I would look for a name brand that I
would put on my
hit list as kind of the ideal person I
want to be partnered up with and that
person can help bring a lot more
attention to your brand yeah for me when
I was launching my website to have
content for entrepreneurs I want a
Donald Trump because at the time he had
the apprentice show it were at one feel
for entrepreneurs and everything I built
up was working towards getting Donald
Trump and so I started with friends who
were authors Nick it right for the site
and I use their names to get Seth Godin
Guy Kawasaki and then use their names
yet keep moving up the list and
eventually got the Donald Trump and then
from there just we hit the tipping point
where all of these big name people were
involved we didn't have to market
anymore people just want to come and
contribute so if there's high-end
designers like who's top high-end
designer you want to go after and then
work your path to them and once you get
that person involved you have this whole
back of other people as well you built
all this momentum the mark and almost
takes care of itself because you have
this huge credibility behind you yeah
and you can also decide that Evan you
can uh what you could do is just settle
for go set yourself up with google
alerts for those companies so you're
getting notified when something happens
there or again you want to sign up for
their their newsletters and see how
their marketing themselves and and maybe
you know what their messaging looks like
in the content that's being provided in
those newsletters that's something that
we do here in terms of following your
big targets are I love that and follow
them on Twitter and follow them on
YouTube and engage their stuff you
should be a known quantity to them